bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale du 1213 sur France 3
jusqu'à 13h45 les enseignements des
élections départementales en Bourgogne
avec Éric Sico pour la sonéloire et
lonne Lilian Melet pour la COD d'or et
la Nièvre réaction résultat et invité
tout à l'heure également principal
changement après ce deuxème tour la
droite redevient majoritaire en son
la gauche ne détient plus que le
département de la Nièvre nous allons
donc commencer notre tour d'horizon des
départements par celui de la sonéoire
avec l'UMP André Akari à parelmial il
est passé du statut de leader de
l'opposition à celui de candidat à la
présidence son binôme s'est largement
imposé dans ce canton retour sur la
soirée avec Stéphane Robert et Gabriel
talon
ouais
ouis à to tourn j'avais oublié ah bah
ouais c'est bon ouais ouais c'est bon
ouaisou et ben c'est bon c'est gagné
André Akari est arrivé très tôt pour
assister au dépouillement très
rapidement il s'est isolé dans un coin
de la salle pour recueillir les
informations qui lui remontent des
différents cantons et peu avant 20h la
tendance est à la bascule du conseil
départemental à droite le leader de
l'opposition se veut encore prudent
j'attend déjà la confirmation
effectivement pour savoir si le
département bascule effectivement la
tendance nous fait dire que
vraisemblblement on serait 16 13 voilà
donc après effectivement je pense que
c'est le fruit d'un travail constant
aussi d'une préparation des élections
qui durent depuis des mois et puis il
faut le reconnaître aussi un
mécontentement vis-à-vis de l'actuelle
majorité il est maintenant 20h passé
Jean-Marc nem le maire de parelmonial
vient de déclarer le nom du vainqueur
sur le cantonans surprise André Hari est
élu avec plus de 67 % des voix face au
binôme socialiste la bascule ajouté à
cette victoire le triomphe est total
mais modeste c'est quelque part aussi
une reconnaissance donc je je suis très
heureux de ce score avec Carole
j'aimerais bien que Caro soit là mais
effectivement on est tout à fait
satisfait de ce résultat après un moment
d'échange avec ses soutiens André Akari
s'est rendu en préfecture de Maon le
3ème tour est maintenant à l'ordre du
jour le conseiller départemental réélu
fait figure de favori à la présidence
les prochains jours seront cruciaux dans
cette course au
perchoir et c'est la déception dans le
camp socialiste à la tête de la sonéoire
depuis 2004 dans le canton de louant le
binôme du président sortant Rémy
chintron est sévèrement battu le PS s
réuni à Chalon surs il s'estime victime
d'un vote sanction contre le
gouvernement Christophe Taris et Romain
li les larmes de Nathalie Leblanc devant
les sympathisants chalonnais elle ne
peut retenir
la conseillère générale sortante est bue
dans Chalon 3 un des cantons charnièr
pour le département seulement de voix
séparé la gauche et la droite à l'issue
du premier tour cette fois les carrés de
500 voix c'est la vie politique c'est la
vie politique et moi ce soir je suis
déjà en train de repartir donc c'est une
vraie grosse déception je suis surtout
déçue pour les habitants du canton qui
seront à mon sens et je le dis très
clairement très mal représenté à Chalon
la gauche n'obtient que deux des qure
cantons les militants font grisem comme
dans le département PS ne parvient à
conserver que 13 cantons contre 16 à
l'Union de la Droite le président du
conseil général Rémy chintron battu
largement reconnaît la défaite les
présidents de conseil généraux
malheureusement ont eu tendance à un
vote sanction nos électeurs on voté la
sanction contre ceux qui représentent le
pouvoir et et le pouvoir notamment
national nous espérions pouvoir avoir
ces deux cantons supplémentaires il en
fallait deux supplémentaires pour
pouvoir maintenir la majorité après 11
ans de présidence socialiste le Conseil
Général de son et Loir change donc de
couleur Christophe cyug avait été élu
président en 2004 lors de l'ancienne
bascule il se montre inquiet je suis
profondément bien sûr meurtri par ce
résultat électoral parce que je me
souviens de ce qu' a été la droite
départementale je n'ai pas vu dans ce
qu'il proposait quoi que ce soit qui
puisse m'enthousiasmer pour l'avenir de
la sonéloire et par ailleurs je pense
qu'il y avait un excellent bilan de de
la gauche au Conseil Général de sonéloir
nous allons voir maintenant voir ce qui
va être fait mais mes craintes sont
grandes très très clairement mes
craintes sont grandes pour l'ensemble
des équilibres territoriaux de ce
département le 3ème tour peut désormais
commencer à droite pour savoir qui
deviendra le futur président les autres
principaux résultats en sonné Loir avec
de cantons sur 3 remportés par la droite
à Chalon sur sa Sylvain
Bouillot à Chalon de net victoire pour
Amélie choui et jean-vanet gig élu avec
61 % des voix devant le binôme du PS la
droite chalonnais semble bénéficier de
la dynamique des élections municipales
qui avaient vu la victoire de l'UMP Gill
platré l'Union de la Droite l'emporte
également sur le conton de Chalon 3 le
tandem Bergeret de chaume s'impose face
à la conseillère sortant de PS là encore
l'effet platrait a peut-être joué Isabel
de chum mais première adjointe au maire
de Chalon à montsau les mines après
avoir perdu la ville la gauche perd le
canton Éric Dubreuil et Marie thérè
Friso arrive en tête devant le binôme
d'union de la gauche et enfin à noter
sur le canton de pierre de Br la
victoire du tandem UMP Gru Rufiange dans
une triangulaire difficile face à
l'Union de la gauche et le FM éic so en
soneloir la droite est donc victorieuse
mais ce n'est pas un rain de Maré on
avait dit que ce serait serré hein et
bien ça a été le cas bien sûr la droite
a clairement gagner et àouant la gifle
infligée au président sortant en est la
parfaite illustration la gauche peut
avoir des regrets car au lendemain du
premier tour elle pouvait encore
conserver le département mais elle n'a
pas su créer de dynamique entre les deux
tours en faisant émerger par exemple un
futur patron Rémy chintron quasiment
éliminé au premier tour arnaau
Montebourg parti Thomas tevenou
contraint à la discrétion nul doute les
électeurs ont pu être désarsenés par ses
absences et les remous autour de ces
personnalités et cela a été fatale la
défaite est née à oururou surs la
gaucheie était en tête avec plus de 100
voix d'avance au premier tour et dans la
même triangulaire au second elle perd le
canton de 30 voies la participation en
hausse a profité à ses adversaires autre
regret les division du premier tour ont
laissé des traces elles sont notamment à
l'origine de la perte du canton d'tin 1
où le binôme de gauche ne fait pas le
plein de ses voix alors que celui de
droite amplifie nettement son résultat
division plus contexte national très
défavorable il n'en fallait pas plus
pour que le Conseil départemental
bascule nous poursuivons avec Lyon seul
département où le Front national va donc
siéger l'essentiel des résultats avec
bintous
sidib virage à droite toute pour Lyon
les binômes de l'UMP udi et divers
droite rafent la mise c'est le cas à
Saint-Florentin avec la victoire de
gérrard André et marieur capitain la
gauche subit un revers électoral dans
Lyonne en perdant 10 conseillers symbole
de cet effondrement au les candidats de
gauche ne parviennent qu'à sauvegarder
un canton sur quatre victoire d'un
binôme divers gauche à vincel et à
joignny Nicolas set réussi à sauver le
canton face au FN mais ce n'est pas le
cas à Villeneuve où le duo frontiste
devance la gauche le national contrra de
conseillers dans la nouvelle assemblée
départementale les seuls de
Bourgogne Lyon conforte donc sa majorité
de droite Eric son département résume à
lui seul ce qui s'est passé au plan
national oui d'abord avec une vague
bleue encore plus impressionnante ici
qu'ailleurs la droite avait 27 élus dans
Lyonne elle en a aujourd'hui 34 sur un
total de 42 elle a su mobiliser ses
électeurs he illustration à Avallon où
la gauche a fait le plein de ses voix du
premier tour mais où 500 électeurs de
plus sont allés voter tous pour le duo
um c'est ce qui fait la différence
Lyonne illustre aussi parfaitement le
Front républicain comme à ponturon par
exemple plus de 2 tiers des électeurs de
gauche sont allés voter pour les
candidats de droite dans les cantons où
il y avait un danger de voir un binôme
FN élu en revanche l'élection des deux
candidats FN illustre non seulement la
montée en puissance de l'extrême droite
mais aussi la porosité de son électorat
avec celui de la droite à Villeneuve un
tiers des électeurs de droite seulement
a voulu faire barrage au FN et cela n'a
donc pas suffit dernier point la gauche
est anéantie dans Lyonne on l'a vu 15
élus auparavant seulement 5inq
aujourd'hui une claque monumentale il
n'y a plus d'opposition de ce côté-là
mais comme la nature a horreur du vide
et bien l'opposition est interne à la
droite et là la bataille ne fait que
commencer la Côte d'Or maintenant où la
droite est donc confortée en s'emparant
de canton comme celui de Montbar des
fêes du sortant PRG Patrick molinauz
revanche pour l'UDI Laurence sport battu
lors des cantonales de 2011 Bintou sidib
et Jean-Louis Saintin étaient à Monbar
hier soir le vino marf Laurence SP a
obtenu
4228 voix soit
53,48
%. 583 voix séparent les deux formation
le résultat est sans appel ce soir
contrairement en 2011 aucune
contestation de l'élection ne sera faite
Laurence spte candidate malheureuse des
dernières cantonnal obtient sa revanche
après la ville de Montbar le canton
passe lui aussi à droite Mar FR et
Laurence SP deviennent les nouveaux
conseillers départementaux on a fait la
même campagne au deème tour qu'au
premier proche des gens et nous on
mélange pas tout on est conseill
départemental on s'occupe des gens et on
ne fait pas de la politique politicienne
et on ne parle pas forcément de Paris
c'est sûrement ça qui a fait la
différence les gens veulent qu'on
s'occupe d'eux et qu'on soit naturel pas
frimeur un tacle en direction de Patrick
molinau conseiller général durant 13 ans
et dont le mandat ne sera pas renouvelé
le binôme qu'il forme avec Marion
montouachon n'a pas réussi à convaincre
les électeurs des candidats éliminés au
premier tour visiblement l'essentiel des
voix du Front national se sont reporté
sur Madame porte sans doute la politique
du gouvernement est sanctionné ce soir
et puis ce redécoupage et cette réforme
que j'ai combattu ben voilà provoque les
résultats attendus euh ou plutôt pas
attendu mais en tout cas craint donc
voilà mais on va continuer de travailler
euh on est conforté sur nos communes
dans le canton de
venaret l'affrontement s'annonçait très
serré mais ici comme ailleurs en Côte
d'Or la droite ressort victorieuse de
ses élections et même une gauche unie
n'aura rien pu y faire nette victoire de
la droite en Côte d'Or elle gagne donc
six sièges le détail avec Lise
riger à nuit-sint-georges le duo emmené
par Hubert Poulot l'emporte avec 234
voix d'écart face au candidat de la
gauche affaibli dans les zones R rural
victoire également à jeanlis du tandem
UMP divivers droite loin devant le Front
national la droite gagne aussi grâce au
front républicain à brasé en pleine le
désistement des candidats de la gauche
après le premier tour a bénéficié à
Emmanuel coin et Gill delpo de son côté
la gauche résiste bien dans les cantons
dijeunais elle en gagne 4 sur 6 dont
Dijon 2 pour le duo miokenders mais
aussi Dijon 3 avec amideluni en dépit de
nombreuses divisions la gauche limite la
case dans les cantons p érique et sauve
notamment chenauve mais aussi l'onvie
avec Christophe Lucan et Céline tonau
autre victoire sur le canton de talent
une bonne surprise pour la gauche Lilian
Meulet en code d'or François Sauvadet
président sortant conforte donc sa
majorité oui François sauadet est plus
que jamais au centre de l'échiquier en
2008 il avait pris l'assemblée à l'UMP
en 2011 il avait desserré les taux et
hier soir on est passé de 2320 à 28 18
une large majorité qui s'appuie quasi
exclusivement sur la partie rurale du
département la gauche est en train de
disparaître des campagnes dans la plaine
de la saun autour de nuit-sint-georgees
ou encore dans le Nord de la Côte d'Or
en revanche la citadelle dijonaise a
mieux résisté que certains de
l'imaginent quatre cantons sur 6 sur la
ville quatre cantons sur 6 à la
périphérie avec l'élection figure de
prou du maire de Dijon et président de
la Communauté urbaine à la mot le Front
national espérait entrer au conseil
départemental par la porte de Brazet le
Front républicain lui a été fatal le
binô UMP d'Emmanuel coin progresse de
1400 voix à mettre en R rapport bien
évidemment avec les 1800 voix du
candidat de gauche qui s'est retiré
reste pour François Sauvadet le rappel
d'une opposition de droite en Côte d'Or
avec la perte du canton de talent causé
en partie par une candidature dissidente
à droite soutenue par le sénateur Alain
houperre qui nous projette déjà en
réalité dans les prochaines élections
régionales la Nièvre enfin seul
département à rester à gauche comme dans
le canton de ne2 avec le F historique du
Parti socialiste où le binôme de la
sortante Delphine Fleury remporte un
duel contre le Front national arrivé en
tête au premier tour le récite de la
soirée avec François l tour et
Jean-François Guilmard Front national
173 au local de campagne du PS on attend
avec fébrilité les résultats du dernier
bureau de vote du canton national
239 Parti socialiste 324
ou Delphine Fleury peut sourire le PS
devance le Front national dans le canton
de never2 territoire historiquement
dominé par le PS
le surs républain a eu lie c'est le
résultat d'un travail de de plusieurs
mois maintenant pour la campagne c'est
vrai que c'était une campagne qui était
difficile dans un contexte extrêmement
dur beaucoup
d'abstention une montée du Front
national qui est
important beaucoup de candidatures au
premier tour enfin beaucoup des
candidatures au premier tour y compris
des candidatures de confusion on va dire
mais bon voilà là ce soir ben je
remercie évidemment tous les électeurs
tous ceux qui ont appelé à faire front
contre le Front national tous les
républicains parce que j'ai bien
conscience que je dois ce vote pas
uniquement au g de gauche hein même si
la gauche a eu le sursaut nécessaire au
palais du CAL Christophe gaillard
candidat FN même s'il n'a pas la
connaissance de tous les résultats a son
explication sur le scrutin si toutefois
c'était confirmé et qu'on perdait on
perdra dignement quand les autres
gagneront malhonnêtement parce que la
campagne quand on parle de front
républicain la campagne qui a été menée
par le Parti socialiste a vraiment été
une campagne de très mauvais goût avec
beaucoup de démagogie et beaucoup de
peur voilà la peur a été attisée chez
leurs électeurs puis ils ont demandé une
mobilisation avec effectivement le l'UNP
et le l'UDI également et le Front de
Gauche bien sûr qui s'est mobilisé donc
un contre tous tous contre un on est
vraiment très content malgré tout
puisque notre ancrage s'amplifie jour
après jour et élection après élection et
donc ça présage quand même un avenir
plutôt intéressant pour nous le canton
de ner2 a démontré que la gauche peut
rassembler lorsque le Front national
progresse sur ces terres les chiffres à
retenir dans les autres canton Nivernais
c'est avec Elsa
beszin la gauche résiste à Corbini
Fabien Bazin s'impose d'un cheveux le
socialiste est réélu avec seulement 22
voix d'avance autre réélection dans un
fief de gauche celle de Patrice jolie à
Château Chinon sans surprise le
président sortant retrouve son fauteuil
la gauche qui conserve la plupart de ces
fiefs elle s'impose dans les cantons de
fourchambau et de deis face au Front
national elle l'emporte également à 9h1
face au candidat de droite de Denis
Turiot le maire de la ville succès
symbolique de la droite dans ce
département de la Nièvre dans le canton
de cône surloire large victoire du
tandem UMP d'hiver
droite le maire de Neu deit tuot misait
sur la dynamique des municipales pour
lancer des candidatures sans étiquette
sous l'appellation nière avenir dans la
moitié des cantons son mouvement entre
au conseil des départemental avec de
binôes écoutz sa réaction recueilllié
par Régis Guillon globalement pour un
mouvement qui n'existait pas il y a 4
mois de rassemblement sans étiquette
mais de gens de compétences variées et
en tout cas volontaires je pense que
c'est un bon point pour débuter alors
justement à quoi vont servir ces pas
péjoratif de ma part mais à quoi vont
servir ces quatre élus entre une gauche
majoritaire et une droite assez assez
présente est-ce que ce seront des élus
tantôt balançons vers un camp tantôt
vers l'autre ou non mais comment vont-il
vivre dans cette hémicyclez nous sommes
nous-mêmes nous l'avons montré sur les
municipales à nover varen V et d'autres
communes donc nous allons rester
nous-mêmes et nous allons apporter du S
neu des idées qui nous sont propres une
autre façon de faire de la politique une
autre vision du concret ce qu'attendent
les gens et donc nous aurons notre mot à
dire nous soutiendrons les projets qui
sont intéressants pour la NIF qui
peuvent être présentés par d'autres et
nous présenterons les nôtres et nous
présenterons aussi des candidatures
prochainement Lilian la Nièvre c'est
l'exception bourguignonne à gauche dans
ce contexte de défaite dans certains
c'est scénario la Nièvre aurait pu être
le symbole d'une débacle de la gauche
mais elle va finalement symboliser autre
chose dans une défaite nationale limitée
le fief a résisté mieux que dans la
terrible vague bleue des années 90 où un
seul siège avait alors fait la
différence les chiffres bruts de ce 2è
tour parle 29000 voix pour la gauche
28000 pour la droite avec les candidates
deituriot et 21000 pour l'extrême droite
un symbole de ce scrutin le canton de
Corbini fief de la gauche rurale
nivernaise héritière de l'époque
miterandienne renouvelé par le jeune
maire de l'Orme Fabien Bazin le Front
national s'y voyait très haut et comme
dans le département il a été dépassé par
la droite au deuxème tour perdant même
171 voies la droite progressait scrutin
après scrutin mais la force de la vague
nationale n'a pas été suffisante pour
balayer totalement le bilan de Fabien
Bazin qui l'emporte de 22 voix seulement
au final la majorité de Patrice jolie se
réduit mais il conserve sa marche de
manœuvre revoyons à présent
quelques-unes des réactions marquantes
lors de la soirée France 3 Bourgogne
hier à gauche comme à droite les
enseignements de ce second tour ce qui
est plus inquiétant ce soir c'est cette
poussée cette vague du Front national
qui monte qui monte et si on y prend
garde ce parti qui est à part dans la
République risque
d'emporter les rempars républicains et
de faire basculer l'Europe voilà c'est
ça qui m'inquiète ce soir à cet instant
il faut que le gouvernement change de
change de cap voilà c'est une sanction
très forte manuel Vals pourra pas nous
dire dit à l'Assemblée nationale qu'on
ne change rien le gouvernement est
aujourd'hui dans l'échec donc soit les
résultats arrivent désormais très
rapidement soit il va falloir d'arddard
trouver une nouvelle orientation à la
politique gouvernementale on a quand
même un ancrage territorial qui est bien
posé nous allons continuer il va qu se
développer de plus en plus donc non non
ce n'est pas une défaite et donc si on
entend pas le message qui est passé par
les électeurs qui disent nous on est
dans la panade vous ne vous occupez pas
de nous et en plus les pratiques
politiques sont à changé euh dire on va
être candidat à la présidence du conseil
départemental et partir au régional
après ça me paraît dangereux donc là là
il y a un travail de fond que moi je
suis prêt à faire avec mes amis j'y
prendrai toute ma toute ma place en
Revan je pense qu'il faut aussi que la
droite ne soit pas trop confiante dans
une victoire qu'elle n'attribuerait qu'à
elle-même vraiment le Parti socialiste
ne changera jamais je l'entendais tout à
l'heure avec une petite impatience quand
il a dit il faut tirer des enseignements
des scrutins le premier renseignement
est-ce que le premier ministre va s'en
aller parce que le vrai problème
aujourd'hui du mal de vivre des Français
cette élection de ce soir c'est quand
même bien la gifle qui est donnée par
rapport à une politique nationale c'est
pas simplement des anjeux locaux notre
édition spécial continue avec la
Synthèse nationale nous nous retrouvons
à midi55 en Bourgogne d'ici là quand
vous le souhaitez sur france3.fr à tout
à
l'heure